bonsoir patrick ferrasse merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
reprise donc de la capitale provinciale
du tigré est-ce que pour vous c'est un
tournant dans le conflit en quelque
sorte un échec également pour l'armée
fédérale éthiopienne si les informations
que l'on a entendu depuis hier se
confirme ce qu' a priori et le cas
puisque les tigres et un communiqué
normalement en ce moment ce qu'ils
veulent ce qu'il ne faisait pas avant ce
qu'il dira qu'ils ont la situation
change eh oui ce sera un tournant sur un
tournant parce que les tigres et ont
repris mais quel était leur capital en
moins de sept mois tout en luttant en
même temps contre l'armée éthiopienne
l'armée érythréenne et les milices amara
donc ça veut dire que l'offensive et
l'arrivée des troupes tigréenne à
michele est une démonstration de la
compétence militaire et de la suprématie
militaire des tigres et un sur l'armée
éthiopienne sera des conséquences sur le
futur de cette armée éthiopienne si l'on
peut dire donc que ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que oui les tigres et un remporté
une grande victoire qui va être un grand
tournant il faut que l'armée tant que le
développement politique
suivent les rebelles des forces de
défense des graines en soutien de la
population
après vie c'est une région où ce soutien
est pratiquement le quasi unanime et au
vu de ce qui a été fait comme exactions
pillages viols et tueries de civils sous
les la totalité de la population est
derrière le tipi élèves sur le front de
libération des tigres est donc là il n'y
a pratiquement aucun souci à ce faire
ils ont pratiquement les 110 94 100 % de
la population derrière eux
ne pas oublier que beaucoup de jeunes
sont partis dans le maquis pour se
battre et que tu y piller la fin et
femmes alors les états unis à l'irlande
et le royaume uni ont demandé une
réunion d'urgence du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu pour bien comprendre qu est-ce
qui va être mis sur la table lors de
cette réunion
vous devez pas grande chose pour la
bonne raison que la dernière la dernière
réunion du conseil de sécurité s'est
finie sur guînes tout sur quoi de
résolution puisque les chinois et les
russes les
l'angle ok il ya de fortes chances que
si cette résolution mais mettait en
doute la souveraineté nationale de
l'ethiopie elle sera bloquée en cuir il
faut pas s'attendre à une résolution je
crois que c'est vendredi qui aura une
réunion faut pas s'attendre à une grande
résolution sur ce côté là depuis le
début
quand cette sécurisation unis n'a pas
réussi à fournir grand chose comme
résolution est pas plus avec les chinois
que les russes mais même les leaders
africains sur les trois pays africains
qui sont membres non permanents du
conseil de sécurité
donc ne nous attendront pas grand chose
de la part de conseillers côté des
nations semi justement aucune marge de
manoeuvre vous dit en substance
pourquoi cette réunion c'est une réunion
pour la forme pour faire passer quelques
messages pour tenter de faire passer un
message sur l'obligation de traiter ce
terreau du tigre cas où il est de la
famille il d'écurie des exactions
commises mais ça fait bien six mois sept
mois celui de ce conseil de sécurité n'a
absolument rien produit les seuls qui
dans la sphère au récit et de mettre un
petit peu le couteau sous la gorge au
gouvernement et aux pièces les
américains le reste c'est ses silences
complices sur la planète si l'on peut
dire que ce soit l'union européenne
union africaine
vous n'avez absolument rien vu de la
part de ces trois organisations
multilatérales que ce soit via sont
unies l'union européenne l'union
africaine les seuls ce sont les
américains qui ont acquis et qui auront
peut-être un jeu à jouer si l'on peut
dire dans les futures négociations qui
vont devoir s'installer à ce qu'on ne
voit pas comment à bien mettre pourra se
passer de faire revenir les mains dans
le jeu au pied dans le jeu politique
éthiopien le premier ministre dont fait
référence à mohammed a reçu le prix
nobel de la paix en 2019
aujourd'hui semble-t-il bien changer ce
qu'on peut craindre que l'ethiopie
devienne une dictature
je pense que ce qui vient de se passer
au tigre à il va montrer que la
dictature n'est pas pour demain
je ne pense pas qu'à bien mais
d'aujourd'hui va devoir continuer sur la
même ligne de conduite qu'il a fait
depuis trois ans malgré les résultats
des élections qui vont être donné d'ici
peu de temps
ces résultats des élections vont être
entachée par ce que vous avez donné
comme événement c'est à dire que la
prise de mekele par les tigres est une
région état qui renaît son plaisir
forcément ils vont se battre jusqu'au
bout ne serait ce que pour retrouver la
conformité de leurs territoires de leur
politique si l'on peut dire et il va
falloir qu'il va falloir qu'il joue dans
le jeu politique et qui au pire et d
toute l'astuce est là l'intelligence
d'abia main doit être décidé de faire
revenir à la table des discussions si
l'on peut dire parce qu'il est obligé de
les faire venir
ils n'ont pas voté pour les élections
qui se sont déroulées il ya quelques
jours
et là il va bien falloir en tenir compte
6 % de la population si non négligeable
surtout que je retiens de vous rappeler
que c'est grâce aux tigres rien que ben
keith tout est tombé en 1991
donc les tigres ont une part importante
dans l'histoire de l'équipe
un cessez-le-feu a été décrété jusqu'en
octobre est ce qu'elle sera respectée
selon vous à mon avis ce que vous ferez
tiré dans un premier temps c'est
reconfigurer la totalité du territoire à
leurs mains c'est à dire qu'ils ont
expulsé les erythréens l'armée mexicaine
et les homards et donc reprendre
totalité de leur territoire se dire que
même ce que les amarres à leur ont volé
si l'on peut dire au début de confiance
non vraiment ils vont le récupérer donc
ça la première instance ce sera là après
ce serait de revenir en fonction de ce
que le problème au gouvernement fédéral
va décider de revenir sur un jeu
politique au sein de l'équipe i donc
l'avenir n'est pas rose
on peut dire on est parti pour une
longue période d'instabilité et à mon
avis bien triste aujourd'hui mais à bien
mettre va devoir
mais c'est un petit peu sa garde il ne
veut absolument pas discuté avec le
front de libération des tigres
or c'est ça va être de celles
représentant dutil de la région et y va
fort qu'il négocie avec eux et ils
reviennent en force puisqu'ils seront
incontournables dans les négociations ne
pas oubliez vous disais tout à l'heure
l'alarmé est en déroute le gouvernement
intérimaire est en déroute aussi c'est
quand même une sacrée humiliation pour
quelqu'un qui avaient pronostiqué une
guerre rapide et puissante
merci beaucoup patrick